in milan we have the opportunity to do
several things, that is to say that for
example we can do training
can give courses to students
or to employees of companies
to ensure a technological transfer
we can also learn
to do  applied research is
fundamental for applied research
it will be done with companies
or with non-
profit organizations such as hospitals, for example,
we can also do consulting for
companies, especially small start-
ups, then that's it  cool because they do
n't really have the opportunity to interact
with other companies to make
room, I see us a bit like the
Robin Hoods of artificial intelligence
[Music]